with me in the studio is Joelle Howard
Taylor vice president of Liberia CCN
been in for the world Health Summit
madam how atella many thanks for your
time now we just saw a report about DRC
struggling to tackle Ebola Liberia has
been successful in dealing with the
disease how are you working together
with affected countries to to tackle
this epidemic as a result of the Ebola
epidemic in Liberia a civilians a
reporting system was put in place is a
regional one across West Africa there is
a whole team of medical personnel that
have been trained to deal with it I'm
not sure we've gotten any requests from
the DRC but I think the information that
was provided to when our processes are
free to members of the African Union on
how we tackled Ebola and how we're able
to defeat it amongst the three countries
that were heavily affected so there's an
issue of early detection surveillance
getting them to the clinics that are
necessary and dealing with the disease
so it doesn't spread beyond where it is
containment containment is is critical
exactly now you're calling for world
leaders and politicians to prioritize
implementation of universal health
coverage but many own country complain
about the lack of health equipment lack
of drugs high maternal mortality so how
serious is your government about health
coverage and I think all of us as
national governments that have signed on
to the sustainable development goals
project which says leave no one behind
must continue to work towards this if
you look across the African spectrum and
maybe across West Africa I don't think
you'll find any country that has
universal health coverage what we're
doing at this point is looking at all of
the options that are available so we can
begin initially with children under five
and pregnant women I think that proposal
is being worked on by the Minister of
Health and we're hoping we can get it
online as soon as possible taking into
consideration all of the other issues
that we have
but universal health coverage is not
just providing an option for someone to
go into a facility if you say it's
making sure that those facilities are up
to par
the laboratories are actually working so
that when you do your testing people
will know that you have a particular
disease and not the other one so we're
working on those issues we have a few
health facilities that are being
upgraded we're building some new ones
the president has initiated a process
where we're looking at a hospital for
the military particularly for those in
the Secret Service and security and
military installations so that they to
have access so we're doing the best we
can is a very costly thing as you know
but we just have to start one solution
at a time I guess I challenges for
librarians to understand this because
there's been recent protests for health
officials were involved you know
complaining about the state of health
facilities and all your government came
to power promising to fight poverty and
of course corruption but many Liberian
see they don't see any improvement since
first name VI came into power what do
you say I say that governance and growth
and development is a process it's not an
event and our government is trying we've
put in place of proper general framework
for health and education and
infrastructure development the
president's first agenda item is
infrastructure development during the
rainy seasons which lasts six to nine
months half of the country is cut off
you can't get medicines you can't get
any kind of equipment there and so he
taught the first thing to do was to
ensure that the rules there are being
done is that is it a case of Priory to
here because many are complaining
poverty and nothing has changed is this
the first step to take the first step is
that people are separated and it
shouldn't be people should be able to
get to the rest of the country to
provide the services where those
services are available in Monrovia in
some of the urban areas again we're
building but they're areas in the south
is that has no access and I think if we
talk about leaving no one behind who
must ensure that everybody has access
he's also working on an agriculture part
of it which i think is our greatest
strength because we do have the last
rain forests in a guinea Guinea Liberian
quadrant of our
of our region okay and we're trying our
best to put in place implements for food
security and allowing the young people
can work and help us use what we have in
our hands to make our country secure in
terms of food security okay then the
other things will fall into place
we will end the tear I always say there
should be more time for these
discussions Madame's you Oh Howard
Taylor
vice president of Liberia thanks for
your time it's been a privilege thank
you for putting an eye on what we're
doing in Liberia we'll continue to do
our best